oh yeah we're talking battlefield one
open beta and if you plan on taking to
the skies this time around dice has
added a bunch of new features that
change the air game entirely namely the
ability to change your vehicle's load
outs so let's take a look at some tips
and tricks and becoming that ace and VF
one's open beta the first thing you'll
notice when you hop in a plane are steep
cliffs and canyons your initial reaction
might be to avoid them but hell no baby
it's the best part about the Sinai
desert map you don't have to outmaneuver
a flow in a turning battle your ultimate
goal in a dogfight is to be
unpredictable and out of sight once you
hug a canyon slope and are no longer in
view book it in opposite direction and
if you're really feeling it a chase
weaving through the canyon typically
results in someone crashing in my
opinion the controller button layout is
not working eject and reload should not
be the same damn button return to the
combat area if you're on pc i recommend
changing these putting reloj to your
right bumper if you're on console just
make a conscious effort not to hold
square or X just quickly tap to reload
yes reloading will happen automatically
yet it's not as fast as doing it
yourself and depending on the weapon
it's pretty essential you are reloading
because with these new weapon loadouts
you'll want to have that heavy ammo at
the ready always be reloading but what
exactly are you reloading well let's
take a look at which plane loadout is
right for you the fighters got two to
choose from there's the bomber killer
that's rocking a heavier slower rate
machine gun and then explosive Rockets
the Rockets are practically useless on
ground armor but bombers well those
balsa wood frames wrapped in bed sheets
absolutely love fire it also comes with
a speed boosts letting you quickly flee
to repair and then there's the trench
fighter which is the only load out that
can harass the ground pop the spotting
flare first in to capture flags and
swing back around for your strafing run
it's packing a burst fire of explosive
darts that when time correctly can wreck
infantry
the first of the two bomber loadouts is
firestorm an anti-infantry loadout that
will carve upon large areas and then
there's the torpedo bomber because
nothing beats dropping a freaking
torpedo into a goddamn sand dune I'd
stick to fire storm or broj both
loadouts come with a wing repair gadget
so be sure to have that option at the
ready when things get hairy finally
there's the attack plane the new
loadouts include the airship cluster
comes with explosive rockets they're
there they're great super they're super
useful
get a load of the tank hunter you want
this why it's rocking at 57-millimeter
nose cannon holy God make sure you
reload and have five shells at the ready
because its cooldown is real slow but my
god unlock this beast and you won't want
anything else planned a couple hits on a
heavy tank and follow up with bombs
guaranteed kill Brandon air-to-air
combat is tough at first you'll have to
feel out where to lead shots but again
one hit on a plane's engine will at the
very least disable it more often than
not it's a kill but you will own
everything infantry forces tanks planes
bombers oh
there you have it some tips to the open
beta air game be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more BF one coverage and
as always thanks for watching now get
out there